les yvelines ont vibré au rythme du
handball féminin ce week-end l'équipe de
france des moins de 20 ans était un
plaisir pour participer au tournoi
international juniors une compétition
qualificative pour les championnats du
monde 2016 qui réunissait la slovénie la
macédoine et d'israël
après deux victoires contre les slovènes
30 à 29 et contre les israëliens 44 16
la france se jouer sa qualification
contre la macédoine ce dimanche un match
qu'elles ont dominée de bout en bout
score final 33 à 21 sillage est contente
parce que voilà on a beaucoup travaillé
et un bon instabilité pendant deux
semaines et franchement on a retrouvé de
la stabilité dans l'alger on est content
après mais je sais que beaucoup de monde
ils ont su répondre au défi
grâce à toute la préparation et à leur
côté professionnel airs disciples et on
a réussi à
dominés les macédoniennes donc
voilà c'était la dernière étape pour ce
avec le plusieurs s'arrête ce serait les
slovènes mai
quatre défaites on aurait été privé du
mondial donc on est on
on est vraiment très heureux avec cette
première place du tournoi les bleus
s'envoleront pour la russie en juillet
prochain pour tenter de remporter la
couronne mondiale de la catégorie face
aux meilleures nations internationale
il ya des écuries beaucoup plus forte
que nous mais il faut croire en ce qu'on
proposait il faut faut rester à
travailler et dans la discipline s'est
rattrapé les meilleurs parce que voilà
les indices précédentes on n'a pas fait
des supers résultats pendant les
championnats d'europe 2015 les bleuettes
avait terminé peu glorieuse 9e place en
espagne